[Music]
hey uh
wanna feel really old
iphone 10 was announced two days ago hey
what is up guys mkbhd here and iphone 10
doesn't come out until november a full
month or two after iphone 8 will come
out in september and apple did this on
purpose they're getting two different
new cycles out of two different new
iphones and they'll probably limit
supply like they usually do you know how
apple is but that just means that all
the info that we have about the purch
decision for this phone
is just in the presentation we got on
stage and the hands-on time we got with
it afterwards so i condensed all my
thoughts about this new phone into the
first impressions video which you should
go watch it's new definitely check it
out if you haven't already but from that
video it spawned a whole new sea
of much more interesting questions about
the phone and these are the five most
important of those so number one a big
part of the story for this new iphone
was that they dropped touch id for face
id facial recognition to unlock your
phone and the big question is will it be
just as good well first of all the
actual facial recognition technology is
supposed to be really good it shouldn't
be fooled by a photo of you it shouldn't
be fooled by people who kind of look
like you it should work in the dark a
new question i've seen though is if you
actually have an identical twin that
looks identical to you will that fool it
and the answer is yeah probably will if
your girlfriend holds your phone up to
your face while you're sleeping to
unlock it will that work
no because it won't work when your eyes
are closed you have to open your eyes to
use face id so apple's got your back
there assuming you sleep with your eyes
closed and one weird thing that people
have been talking about is it looked
like face id failed in the first ever
demo that apple gave to the public which
is what they did on stage with that new
iphone let's take a look at exactly what
happened iphone 10 now unlocking it is
as easy as looking at it
and swiping up and you know let's try
that again
ho ho ho
let's uh
go to back up here
and get right in okay so since then
apple has actually come out with an
official explanation for what happened
that they gave to 95 mac which was this
people were handling the device for
stage demo ahead of time and didn't
realize face id was trying to
authenticate their face after failing a
number of times because they weren't
craig the iphone did what was supposed
to do which was require his passcode in
other words face id worked as it was
designed to so that makes perfect sense
you know how if you try the wrong
fingerprint enough times in a row it
will ask you for your password if you do
like i don't know eight ten times in a
row it stops listening to the
fingerprint and just says putting your
pin well apparently it's the same thing
if you try the wrong face too many times
in a row so to me that just raises the
question
if people just look at your phone
randomly is that gonna count as a failed
unlock attempt like will there just be
tons maybe hundreds of failed unlock
attempts if you just leave your phone on
a table for too long and people walk by
and look at it does that count are we
all going to be like craig samsung kind
of doesn't have this problem because
when you raise the phone it doesn't wake
up once you hit the power button then it
starts looking for your iris and it
wakes with the iphone you have raised to
wake so as soon as you raise it up it's
awake and looking for a face
it could have drained battery could it
constantly be looking for the wrong
faces will we constantly be putting in
our passcodes that i don't know
basically i'm just hoping that face id
has been worked on enough and refined
enough that this won't be a problem
because that's why apple took so long to
implement it so number two is
reachability and overall one-handedness
this is actually a really big overlooked
part of the iphone 10 in my original
video i didn't mention it that much but
something you might not notice is this
is actually not a really easy one-handed
phone when you compare it to the current
iphone 7 plus or 8 plus it has a smaller
body yes but it's still a larger display
which means you will have to reach
further no matter how small the bezels
are what made me notice this was having
the home button or the home swipe all
the way at the bottom and the control
center all the way up at the top now
someone who uses control center a lot
that is a serious stretch and i have big
hands so i know right away from there
that means it's gonna be a two-handed
thing for a lot of people i didn't get
to mention that in my original
impressions video but obviously looking
back at the clips you can tell even with
big hands it's not easy so that's
something a lot of people will be using
this device with two hands so number
three is anything about this phone
actually
new
no i mean pretty much every single new
feature we saw demoed on stage or
highlighted or headlined about the
iphone 10 we've seen it before in some
other phone the bezel-less display with
a notch at the top well the essential
phone literally just did that but many
other phones have been bezel-less over
the past couple years in their own ways
qi wireless charging this has been
around for a while as well just last
year galaxy note 8 galaxy s8 lg v30 have
all had wireless charging plus many
others face unlock that was a key new
feature back in the days of android 4.0
plus the note 7 came out last year with
iris scanning even augmented reality
there have been entire phones built
around that experience but the fact is
that doesn't really matter i mean you've
heard this before apple
is never really first to things but they
tend to lag behind and then when it's
well established they leap in and do it
really well and it's well refined that's
what we're crossing our fingers for with
face unlock that's what we're used to
seeing with other apple features that's
what's happening again here and to be
fair i don't really know how they can
say their wireless charging is better
than others
but i am really glad that it's finally
here so number four
this is a thousand dollar phone is this
thing going to be worth the extra money
well that depends on you that's also a
question i've been getting about the
galaxy note 8 the phone i'm reviewing
right now it's about a thousand dollars
the question is always is it worth the
extra money over its closely related
brother phone really i think the better
question is iphone 10 what does it do
for a thousand bucks that the cheaper
new iphone 8 doesn't do so first of all
it's an oled display so it'll have a
higher contrast ratio more saturated
colors pitch black blacks it supports
hdr now
it's just overall going to look better
it's also a higher resolution it's 2436
by 1125 at 458 pixels per inch and you
also now get to say you have a super
retina display and of course the display
is full screen edge to edge much smaller
bezels no chin you also have optically
stabilized both cameras instead of just
one so the telephoto lens should have
much better performance and low light
much better video stabilization etc
but then everything else is exactly the
same the specs the performance the ip67
rating wireless charging bluetooth 5.0
the selfie camera all that stuff is the
same on both so what i'd say is you have
to decide if that premium design and the
full screen oled display are worth it to
you you might be surprised how many
people say yes people we just want the
best possible iphone so the number five
is the little stuff just a bunch of
random little nagging questions like how
do you take a screenshot if there's no
home button anymore well i didn't get to
try this at the event but i'm guessing
it'll move to do it exactly the same way
android does which is power button and
one of the volume buttons and if siri is
triggered by a long press of the power
button
then how do you turn the phone off
that's usually a long press probably
just a much longer press of the power
button so siri is like a two second hold
down to trigger it but actually holding
it for five to eight seconds will get
you that shutdown animation well having
face id as your unlock prevent you from
being able to just like sneak your phone
in class or like sneak use it during
meetings
yes
but also you could just use your
passcode like before we all know the
space gray version of this thing will be
a fingerprint magnet but will a case or
a skin on the back of this phone
interrupt wireless charging the answer
is no so skins are really thin no
problem you can put it on the pad it'll
still work and qi wireless charging i've
seen on many other phones people have
used some pretty thick rubber cases and
put them on wireless charging pads and
they still work so it'll depend on the
thickness of the case you choose but
ideally you can try it in an apple store
and see for yourself so there you have
it guys i think the bottom line for
iphone 10 is this is really one of those
phones where you'll want to wait to see
the reviews before you buy i mean it's
already more expensive than the iphone 8
and it's coming out a little bit after
the iphone 8 as well so you'll have if
you have that luxury of being able to
wait to see if this is the phone you
want to buy do that watch the reviews
then you'll know it is a really
beautiful phone at first glance and in
the hand it'll probably be awesome but
obviously looking at it and actually
spending your money on it are two
completely different things so that's
what i hope to help you with with these
videos but that's pretty much it feel
free to share this one with anyone who
you think might want to know more about
the iphone 10 and of course the
impressions video which i'll link above
or right below the like button but
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you